the search continues for people trapped
in tornado debris in bowling green
kentucky the national weather service
confirms that the city was hit by an
ef-3 tornado lily luciano went out with
a k-9 search and rescue team as they
work to find some of the missing she is
in bowling green about 120 miles east of
mayfield lilia good morning
good morning to you nate it's already
been more than 48 hours since that
tornado struck bowling green killing at
least 11 people 10 or so are still
missing and local authorities tell me
this is still very much a search and
rescue effort involving local county
federal authorities as well as
volunteers and dogs
but what did it sound like a yale or a
more life cycle
[Applause]
when a group of neighbors reported
hearing voices coming from a creek in
bowling green on sunday
like maybe like
here
the fire department police and
volunteers showed up to comb the woods
and the water for any signs of life did
they say uh how far they heard the
screams no just along the path here and
it could be somebody playing i mean it
could be a false alarm a variety of
things
but you have to treat every call
as a true emergency there's dozens of
search and rescue crews here
firefighters and volunteers they're
looking for any sign of life or a person
about two hours ago a couple of
residents heard a voice or said they
heard a voice and perhaps even someone
gasping for air or asking for help
they're not sure whether this is a false
alarm but still people are missing
this is my belgian malawia german
shepherd dog anubis while they work
against the clock dogs trained for
search rescue and recovery become
critical what they're smelling are
hair
blood just different remains and these
dogs can smell way better than we can
you know when the county search crews
didn't have enough dogs for this level
of loss they accepted the help of these
volunteers they're amped up they know
what we're doing they're reading us so
we got we got that potential find on
creek wade and for the handlers it's
hard to keep up i'm just coming out to
get a breather real quick and go back in
there again but a tree
got me got the best of me despite
searching for hours and returning
empty-handed there's no stopping their
quest for survivors so
there's still a chance she'll hope
she'll chance
around me those crews are still
searching and they will continue
throughout the day today but i'm just
looking around and everywhere i look
throughout this block there's barely any
structures that are left standing but
you know what we saw yesterday the
streets were jam-packed with people not
looking to see the wreckage but bringing
food water even containers so that those
survivors that came back home would have
somewhere to put the few belongings that
they could find uh tony
yeah lily are people doing their best to
help one another and if we see your
camera pull back there it there is no
lens big enough we've heard people say
to take in all of the destruction across
those multiple states there uh lilia
thank you very much we saw there in
bowling green guys that's a confirmed
ef-3 tornado which is 136 to 165 mile an
hour winds
we're talking if that were a hurricane a
cat 5 the biggest type of storm the
difference being is just so localized
and it carves a just a really disgusting
path through everything it hits i have
great appreciation and admiration for
the people who are searching that say
they're not going to give up because
they know that can make the difference
somebody
could be underneath that rubble praying
and hoping and waiting that they're
discovered yeah you don't want to give
up 100 and i have to say this thoughts
and prayers they do help yeah but if you
can do more um financially um if you're
local um going out there and helping
physically but if you can give even if
it's just sending food and i'm talking
to the mere reflection of nate burleson
do something because i know that i'm
gonna do what i can so i'm asking
everybody out there to do the same and
nate i heard somebody who was caught in
this say we're asking everybody to do
everything mm-hmm i thought that was a
very good way to put it and and it's
going to be a long-term cleanup it's not
just to do it today it's check in down
the line
all right lilia thanks again